en Russie à un problème qu'ils ont
depuis à peu près 30 ans ils n'ont pas
accepté la fin de l'Union soviétique il
se pense comme un empire d'ailleurs
c'est le réveil des empires quand vous
vous parlez de la Turquie eux ils
pensent en pierre ottoman quand vous
parlez de la Perse de l'Iran il pense en
pierre Perse les Chinois pensent empire
chinois au sens très large 14e siècle et
les Russes s'y pensent empire orthodoxe
un très grand immense espace ils ont
jamais accepté d'être rétracté de
devenir tout petit et d'ailleurs Poutine
le dit dans son condensé de 14 minutes
qui est le résumé de ce qui raconte
depuis 2000 ça fait 21 ans qu'il dit la
même chose mais qui nous ont dit immense
efforts pour ne jamais l'écouter il nous
a fait un condensé en 14 minutes en 1991
vous avez déchiqueté l'URSS et ben on
n'est pas content et donc vous nous
voulons redevenir ce que nous étions une
très grande puissance et donc il le fait
d'abord en le disant ensuite en menaçant
ensuite en intervenant c'est pas la
première fois il a commencé dès 1992-93
en Moldavie un bout de la Roumanie puis
il a continué en Géorgie en 2008 où
c'est Nicolas Sarkozy alors président de
l'Union européenne qui a arrêté
sauver le morceau de Géorgie mais ils en
ont perdu un bout 2014 déjà en Ukraine
car l'Ukraine est en guerre depuis 8 ans
pas depuis 8 mois et puis bah là il est
dans l'affrontement final c'est-à-dire
maintenant j'en ai marre et je vais
montrer de quel bois je me chauffe donc
il est allé jusqu'au bout d'une démarche
ancienne qui a mitonnait très doucement
et monter ça chauffait ça chauffait et
puis là on est dans le principe de la
cocotte-minute le couvercle a pété alors
ce qu'il faut s'inquiéter oui il faut
s'inquiéter pour trois raisons d'abord
il fait ce qu'il dit et dit ce qu'il
fait c'est pas parce que nous on écoute
pas ce qu'il dit on croit pas qu'il va
le faire qu'il le fait pas il a une
rationalité il n'est pas dingue il n'est
pas fou il est extraordinairement
rationnel mais c'est pas notre
rationalité nous on pense toujours qu'il
va pas le faire bien sûr lui il a aucun
problème par exemple pour les
occidentaux la violence et le dernier
refuge de l'incompétence pour les
citations
pour lui la violence a un élément
naturel de la gestion d'une crise il n'y
a pas de problème pour nous la
dissuasion nucléaire c'est l'usage de
l'arme nucléaire quoi qu'il arrive et
donc c'est pas bien pour lui il y a
l'arme nucléaire tactique elle fait
partie de la guerre conventionnelle
normale c'est normal on peut s'en servir
c'est pas interdit et l'arme nucléaire
stratégique c'est vraiment quand les
interviews donc quand on parle d'armes
nucléaires on parle pas de la même chose
avec lui exactement et lui il pense que
c'est utilisable dans des conditions qui
sont précises et particulières et qui
sont les mêmes depuis 1963 car la
doctrine militaire russe c'est une
copié-coller de la doctrine militaire
américaine des années 60 sauf que eux
ils n'ont pas évolué et donc pour lui là
toutes les conditions sont réunies pour
peut-être utiliser alors pas encore
sa défaite ça déroute devant car kif
Kharkov vous savez qu'il y a deux
orthographes lèche le fait qu'il est
perdu environ 80 000 hommes c'est-à-dire
l'essentiel la moitié de la conscription
annuelle de l'armée russe le fait qu'il
est plus d'officier intermédiaire que
les équipements sont des équipements des
années 60 c'est-à-dire grosso modo c'est
du gros rouge qui tâche et pas de la
Romanée-Conti ça tire n'importe où mais
ça tire c'est comme la kalachnikov vous
la mettez dans le sable ou la roulez
dans l'eau vous prenez un bain avec
satire pas droit mais sert leur article
est exactement du même niveau mais il
est en déroute il ne peut pas admettre
la déroute il peut pas perdre mais on
sait maintenant qu'il ne peut pas gagner
non plus et le problème c'est
l'équilibre qui va exister à quel moment
on va arriver à ce que les Chinois qui
viennent de le lâcher c'est ça en plein
milieu du désert on dit cessez le feu
c'est c'est le feu c'est pas la paix
c'est le feu c'est une paix armée qui
ressemble à ce qui s'est passé entre
2014 et 2022 c'est-à-dire un truc où il
y a des escarmouches des difficultés à
un front plus ou moins clair mais au
moins les civils arrêtent de se faire
bombarder et donc aujourd'hui
comme on l'a dit hier c'est sont les
Chinois qui peuvent arrêter les Chinois
viennent alors je pense que les chinois
sont beaucoup beaucoup plus intelligents
et manipulateurs que ce que Poutine
pensait lui espérer avoir une sorte de
Ordre Mondial Alternatif les Chinois les
Russes les Iraniens les Coréens du Nord
sauf que les Chinois eux ils ont envie
de récupérer un gros morceau de la
Russie qui s'appelle la Sibérie pour des
raisons d'expansion totale c'est leur
rêve depuis 8 siècles et en fait ils ont
en perd les filles côté Poutine en le
laissant partir en disant vas-y donc mon
gars et puis un moment Poutine s'est
retourné il y avait personne derrière ni
les armes ni les équipements c'est
incroyable un petit soutien par contre
les Chinois ont acheté pas cher du gaz
et du pétrole russe que les autres
pouvaient pas exporter un peu de un peu
de céréales aussi et de blé voler en
général aux Ukrainiens et là ils
viennent de lâcher en pleine nature les
Indiens qui faisaient la Balance vous
savez c'est un peu l'histoire que quand
un mec de 200 kg parle à un mec de 60
vous l'écoutez Audiard et bah là c'est
quand tu as deux pays d'un milliard
d'habitants qui parlent un petit pays de
200 millions qui est en train
démographiquement de disparaître parce
que c'est ça la grande terreur de
Poutine c'est simple la démographie
russe elle est définitivement horrible
ce pays est en train de disparaître il a
besoin de se requinquer d'une manière ou
d'une autre attention l'annexion de la
Crimée le seul moyen qu'il a eu de ne
pas perdre de la population c'est ça
pour vous donner un exemple donc la
réalité c'est que il est tout seul
désormais et que la menace nucléaire
pour lui est une condition de survie
personnelle c'est pas tellement un
message pour les
occidentaux les Occidentaux savent très
bien qu'il n'y aura pas de frappe
nucléaire sur l'Occident tant que
l'Occident n'est pas le premier donc
entrer en Russie donc là pour l'instant
voilà en tout cas en France il y aura
pas de frappe là la probabilité est
inexistante par contre elle est fort
inexistante tu il y a une déroute russe
vers la Crimée par exemple qui est
vraiment quelque chose d'extrêmement
purulent chez les Russes parce qu'il
considère depuis toujours que ça leur
appartient alors ça appartient ni aux
Russes ni aux Ukrainiens ça appartient
au tatar de Crimée qui ont été
intégralement génocides par Staline et
qui aujourd'hui sont plutôt
pro-ukrainiens que prorus mais enfin ils
sont surtout criméens c'est chez eux et
c'est nulle part ailleurs mais là s'il y
a une déroute trop importante et ce qui
va se passer c'est que
tout ce qui est en train de continuer là
c'est que c'est Véro Donetsk et lougans
vont probablement tomber parce que la
poussée
ukrainienne est considérable et que les
rues sont pas réussi à remonter ni les
troupes ni de l'équipement donc il
bombarde ils bombardis bombardi bombarde
parce qu'ils ont plus que ça de
l'artillerie qui d'ailleurs n'est même
pas dans les zones de combat mais en
Russie espérant que jamais personne ne
tape leur artillerie là où ils sont la
partie Kerson est grosso modo symbolique
pour les Ukrainiens cette fois la partie
Mario Paul est essentielle pour ce qu'on
appelle la privatisation de la mère
d'Azov ça c'était la seule élément
stratégique donc ce que veut absolument
sauver Poutine c'est la partie qui est
complètement à droite de votre carte et
absolument de manière définitive la
Crimée qui est un élément de la Russie
et c'est pour ça que Poutine parle de
novorosia il parle de la Russie au sens
large et donc ça c'est pas touche à la
Crimée la Crimée j'utiliserai l'arme
nucléaire voilà pour tout le reste donc
là ça se discute Alain la question que
tout le monde nous pose sur les réseaux
sociaux
où en est l'armée française est-ce qu'on
est
est-ce qu'on est capable de se défendre
contre la Russie ou pas du tout alors
régulièrement je pense que vous devez
offrir à votre femme ce qu'on appelle la
Médaille Miraculeuse je t'aime moins
qu'il y a ou plus qu'hier - demain
dans une situation qui est meilleure
qu'hier et elle va continuer à
s'améliorer mais elle part de très très
loin parce que vos collègues qui ayant
fini leurs études à l'intègre et son
passé à Bercy avait décidé en 89,90
qu'on avait plus besoin d'armer c'est ça
que nous allions vivre après la chute du
mur de Berlin dans un petit monde de
bisounours sur eux gambadans dans la
salle que nous n'aurions plus des
adversaires mais que des clients et des
fournisseurs exactement et donc tout
allait bien la vie était belle et
surtout on avait plus besoin d'armer et
donc ils ont réduit réduire réduit
l'armée jusqu'au moment ou à l'os elle
était en train de disparaître notamment
l'armée de terre et puis heureusement ou
malheureusement les attentats ont permis
un coup de Jarnac voulu par un mini
Jean-Yves Le Drian on va inventer un
truc qui ne sert à rien sentinelle mais
on va sauver 8000 postes de militaires
et donc il a sauvé l'armée de terre
depuis il y a eu un chef d'état-major le
général De Villiers qui a dit écoutez
les gars si vous remettez pas du budget
nous allons avoir des ennemis c'est pas
seulement le terrorisme le monde est en
train de se recomposer et il a été puni
par
l'État qui a dit tu as pas le droit de
dire ça à des parlementaires donc il
s'est fait jeter et l'actuel chef
d'état-major désormais a dit écoutez moi
j'ai une vision stratégique nous allons
vers une guerre dite de haute intensité
ce qui est très exactement ce qui se
passe en Ukraine alors il est pas allé
jusqu'au bout la guerre de haute
incendie c'était quand tu envoies 15
millions d'obus et que tu es en guerre
tous les jours tout le temps sur tous
les fronts financiers économiques
sociales céréales c'est une vraie
internet cyber militaire bombardement
bref à la totale c'est la ce qu'on
appelle la guerre globale et donc il a
dit c'est un sujet essentiel il faut
absolument qu'on se prépare à la gare de
haute insensible il n'avait pas vu que
ça allait au-delà de ça que c'était
notamment la haute intensive et de la
longue intensité car la guerre de trois
jours qui devait mettre l'Ukraine à plat
et ben ça fait 8 mois et c'est une
guerre globalisée pas mondiale il y a
une centaine de protagonistes qui
fournissent des armes des équipements
des obus des munitions éventuellement
des mercenaires mais ce qu'on a deux
côtés est-ce qu'on avait les moyens
comme vous dites voilà que notre armée
se reconstruire ce qu'on avait les
moyens d'envoyer tout ce qu'on envoyait
à l'Ukraine non non ma prise non pas sur
les stocks mais sur les équipements
utiles donc si demain on a un conflit en
France avec tout ce qu'on a envoyé en
Ukraine on se retrouve des mini bah si
on ne remplace pas
du jour au lendemain mais on a ouvert
justement c'est l'intérêt de la chose
c'est que toutes les équipes toutes les
usines qui avaient été fermées c'est
comme le c'est comme pour le covid plus
de masque plus d'usine masse plus
d'oxygène plus d'usine d'oxygène mais ça
peut mais ça peut être médicament plus
d'usine de médicaments on peut
construire assez vite mais en tout cas
tout le monde a décidé que ce qui
m'était 5 ans pouvait en mettre 3 et
surtout qu'on n'est pas obligé d'acheter
des équipements ultra sophistiqués qui
sont très longs et très difficiles à
créer alors que les Russes viennent de
faire la démonstration et les Ukrainiens
aussi que du bon milieu matériel des
années 60 et efficace ça donnait des
résultats en tout cas pour bloquer une
armée d'invasion et éventuellement
reconquérir du terrain donc là vous
parlez de 3 ans si il y a un conflit là
dans les prochains mois on n'est pas on
n'est pas encore prêt donc il faut leur
dire attendez revenez dans trois ans les
gars deux minutes on est prêt voilà qui
est le même que celui de Poutine c'est
tu as des bombes nucléaires nous aussi
et surtout la problématique c'est
qu'elle nous elles sont stratégiques
c'est qu'elles sont faites pour que
justement cette question ne se pose pas
alors tout le débat c'est tout le monde
a bien compris que la fin du monde n'est
pas la volonté de Poutine non et ce
n'est pas la nôtre très important de
leur signaler il ne veut pas la fin du
monde il veut juste dire écoutez les
gars j'ai un problème qui s'appelle
l'Ukraine il faut qu'on trouve une
solution sur le crâne et la moitié du
discours de 14 minutes c'est on était
prêt à trouver une solution avec les
Ukrainiens ils avaient donné leur accord
on était au bord d'un compromis d'un
traité de paix d'un machin d'un truc et
puis Washington et les méchants
occidentaux n'en ont pas voulu mais ça
c'est une vérité alternative c'est fake
mais dans la réalité il souligne chaque
fois qu'il est prêt à un accord une
négociation et depuis que les Chinois
lui ont dit maintenant c'est le temps du
cesser le feu il lui reste exactement 4
à 8 semaines avant l'hiver pour régler
une partie du problème c'est à dire
s'arrêter et dire bon voilà les lignes
du front et puis c'est on attend qu'il
se passe autre chose ça sera 14 14 18 ou
ça sera
Verdun bref quelque chose qui n'est pas
encore résolu alors aujourd'hui est-ce
que la Russie
s'il y a une escalade que la Russie
pourrait attaquer la France vous l'avez
dit non tout à l'heure mais si en Crimée
voilà il y a une escalade si la France
n'intervient pas en tant que France pas
seulement en fournissant des armes mais
en entrant sur le terrain militaire en
intervenant avec des soldats sur le
terrain
ukrainien est-ce que c'est possible ça
que la France à un moment disons bah si
par exemple Poutine envoie une arme
nucléaire tactique en Ukraine donc oui
la question de la réaction de l'OTAN et
donc des États-Unis d'Amérique c'est
tout ça se discute entre Washington et
Moscou les autres ils font un peu
figuration quand même non ces figuration
nous la France bah on est les seuls à
avoir une indépendance nucléaire les
Anglais n'en ont plus depuis longtemps
donc nous sommes la dernière puissance
nucléaire en Europe donc on a un espace
un peu plus grand mais nous sommes liés
à l'Alliance atlantique et dans cette
affaire vous avez pu noter que c'est
l'alliance atlantique qui est l'élément
moteur de la réponse à l'invasion russe
donc aujourd'hui il y a très peu de
chances il y a très peu de chance que
nous soyons directement touché si nous
n'ent pas directement dans le conflit
alors pour l'instant on est une partie
au conflit en tant que fournisseur mais
on n'est pas belligérant en tant
qu'acteur moi j'ai une autre question à
vous poser qui alors là je sais pas si
vous êtes au courant j'ai entendu un
truc je vous le livre alors je sais pas
une difficile fake news ou pas il paraît
qui durait des coupures d'électricité
très rapidement là dans les prochaines
semaines pendant une durée de 6 mois il
paraît qu'il veut avoir on va être
obligé d'avoir des coupures
d'électricité en France est-ce que c'est
ce que vous avez entendu aussi non pour
l'instant la remise en état d'une partie
du parc nucléaire qui était soit
maintenant soit avec des corrosion
anciennes et qui sont dus à peu près aux
mêmes errements que sur nos armées c'est
à dire quand investissent pas dans le
renouvellement du parc nucléaire bah à
un moment ils vieillit et puis il tombe
en panne c'est comme vos voitures si
vous les amenez pas régulièrement à la
maintenance elle dépérissent
naturellement mais une partie du parc
nucléaire va être remis en
fonctionnement là d'ailleurs dans des
jours qui viennent donc quatre au moins
réacteurs
et j'ai le problème pour son concordant
qui disent que voilà il y aurait non ce
qu'on appelle des délaissages
c'est-à-dire si il fait très froid ici
la consommation augmente beaucoup il y a
un risque de délaissage le délestage
n'est pas une coupure c'est un espèce de
mouvement tournant et qui tourne et qui
concerne en général les très gros
consommateurs d'électricité c'est à dire
des grosses entreprises c'est ça oui
pour les grosses entreprises
ça ne risque d'arriver c'est une
possibilité qui a été annoncée
d'ailleurs
le retour en fonction d'une partie du
parc nucléaire réduite de manière
considérable ce risque après s'il fait
-20 qu'est-ce que vous dites aux
Français moi je vous pose toutes les
questions et je voudrais poser la
question ici aussi
français qui disent comme Daniel nous
l'a dit hier ça n'est pas notre guerre
qu'est-ce que vous leur dites parce que
Daniel c'est ce que tu disais à peu près
hier il y a beaucoup de gens qui pensent
ça ça n'est pas notre gars et il y a
aussi des Russes qui pensent ça parce
que il y a eu des manifestations et des
Français
mais oui qu'est-ce que vous dites de ça
parce que il y a quand même des gens qui
pensent que la prise aussi on a laissé
passer la Crimée en 2014 je pense que ça
n'a empêché personne de dormir pourquoi
aujourd'hui on est aussi virulent et
pourquoi on prend des risques nous
pourrons différentes je trouve je disais
que j'entendais uniquement des discours
qui étaient assez belliqueux et qui
allaient dans le sens d'une escalade
alors que il semblerait que le principe
de responsabilité de l'Occident en tout
cas de l'Union européenne devrait a
priori être de faire tout pour trouver
des solutions pour amener à la paix ça
fait ça fait 8 mois qu'on cherche la
paix
quand vous entendez les Français dire
c'est pas notre guerre on a rien à faire
là-bas enfin il faut qu'on arrête de de
s'investir autant qu'est-ce que vous
leur dites alors c'est pas notre guerre
c'est sûr mais il se trouve qu'on a
la réalité c'est ce n'est pas notre
guerre mais qu'on le veuille ou pas ça
va le devenir alors pourquoi on appelle
la même logique avec l'Arménie
on peut avoir la même logique avec
la peur de l'Arménie c'est la Russie
c'est la Russie qui est l'intervenant on
a pas eu les mêmes mots aussi on appelle
ça avec l'Afrique voilà
on n'est pas intervenu on a laissé les
populations
c'est un peu plus loin et ensuite nous
étions la puissance coloniale et comme
vous le savez la puissance coloniale vit
entre le remord colonial et le fait de
vous avez voulu l'indépendance des
merdez-vous mais l'Arménie n'est pas
la réalité des des comme les Anglais
d'ailleurs ils ont les mêmes problèmes
que nous eux le font un peu pire parce
que quand ils tirent de quelque part il
crée le chaos pour l'éternité et plus si
affinités ils y mettent une frange bonne
volonté nous on est un peu honteux et on
sait plus bien comment souhaiter mais
dans la réalité plus c'est loin moi on
le voit plus c'est prêt plus ça nous
concerne mais justement en fait il y a
quelques mois quand la guerre a commencé
et quand les Français étaient suspendus
aux lèvres d'Emmanuel Macron savoir ce
qu'il allait dire et qu'il a dit ok je
m'en vraiment les Français ont quand
même eu peur on était entre la peur et
bien sûr la solidarité il faut aider son
prochain est-ce que Emmanuel Macron
aurait pu réagir différemment peut-être
pour être un peu plus tempéré et
peut-être moins nous mettre dans la
sauce aussi quelque part malgré tout moi
je pense qu'il a fait ce qu'il pouvait
pour essayer de régler un problème dont
les principaux opérateurs sont là à
Moscou l'autre à Washington et nous au
milieu donc il a essayé de trouver un
espace ne d'ailleurs sans discours on a
changé ni à ça intéressant parce que
c'est le premier discours goien
d'Emmanuel Macron c'est le même discours
que le général de gaultenait au moment
de la création des Nations Unies où la
France disait je n'irai au Conseil de
sécurité que si j'écris une partie de la
Charte des Nations Unies et si je
représente les petits pays qui ne sont
pas alignés entre Moscou et justement
Washington alors à l'époque la Chine
faisait partie de ces petits grands pays
l'un des apparaissaient pas encore très
bien puisqu'elle n'avait pas encore
obtenu son indépendance mais il y a eu
un choix et il est revenu là-dessus en
parlant justement des non alignés et de
cet espace intermédiaire où la France
essaye de réexister
tout en étant parti au conflit et engagé
dans l’alliance Atlantique puisque
l'article 5 fait que quoi qu'il arrive
nous sommes solidaires de nos
partenaires
l'autre question voilà qu'on était en
train de poser au chroniqueur voilà
c'est en cours voilà et puis il faut pas
oublier non plus que la France ou les
autres pays européens n'ont pas
tellement de leçons à donner vu que
certes pas dans les dernières années
mais au cours des dernières décennies ou
siècle ça n'a été que des opérations de
reconquête de territoires etc donc
pourquoi la Russie ne se permettrait pas
elle aussi de conquérir l'Ukraine comme
nous la conquéri l'Alsace-Lorraine ou
d'autres pays d'autres d'autres
territoires voilà et puis il ne faut pas
l'oublier non plus qu'il y a plein de
pays qui sont en paix mais qui pour qui
la guerre serait un profit parce que la
guerre profite toujours même au pays qui
sont pas concernés par la guerre pour
après parce que il y a des questions de
reconstruction d'armement c'est des
opérations qui qui rapportent énormément
d'argent ou vainqueur évidemment donc
faut toujours être dans le tour des
vainqueurs donc participer aussi i am
mouvement de de de guerre vous avez pas
compris j'étais peut-être été élevé le
niveau
j'adore mais c'est vrai qu'il y a un
petit un petit voilà c'est c'est c'est
en tout cas j'espère que les gens
captent ces 8
mieux que nous ici non la question qu'on
vous posez la série que c'est la France
doit-elle vraiment durcir le ton face à
cette valadimir poutine on a la vidéo de
d'Emmanuel Macron regardez à l'ONU et
vous allez me dire ce que vous en pensez
oui ou non parce que c'est vrai que
c'est la question que se pose il y a
beaucoup de Français qui disent on est
dans une sauce dans laquelle on n'a pas
envie d'être regardez ce à quoi nous
assistons depuis le 24 février dernier
est un retour à l'âge des impérialismes
et des colonies
la France le refuse je suis aussi que
certains pays ici représentés sont
restés dans une forme de neutralité à
l'égard de cette guerre
alors oui c'est bon on donne des
informations quelqu'un qui vient de
donner des trucs alors qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez vous avez vos petites en
quartier au play s'il vous plaît réagir
mes chéries Gilles Verdez moi je suis
frappé par vos propos vous venez
l'expliquer que finalement notre armée
n'est pas en état au niveau nucléaire
maintenant on est plus qu'une puissance
moyenne et c'est vrai que quand on voit
le discours belliqueux du président de
la République on se dit est-ce qu'il y a
pas un décalage c'est-à-dire que on n'a
pas les moyens de tenir ses propos là et
peut-être que le fait de d'être si
agressif mais les Français dans une
situation difficile alors que si on
regarde notre armée on ferait mieux
peut-être d'être un peu moins belliqueux
c'est pas un discours belliqueux hein
[Rires]
il y a la partie que vous entendez et il
y a la partie qu'il faut lire c'est
comme le discours de Poutine quand il
lit le discours de Poutine il y a plein
de contradictions et de trucs
extrêmement bizarres on sent qu'il a été
bricolé à la dernière minute qu'il a
repris des morceaux et tout en ouvrant
des utilisateurs quand vous écoutez le
discours de Macron il y a cette partie
là du genre pas gentil méchant machin et
puis à la partie non alignée le temps
est venu de la négociation toute façon
ça serait négociera autour d'une table
je laisse toujours la porte ouverte et
donc il y a toujours deux mouvements
dans un discours politique
particulièrement aux Nations Unies où
personne n'écoute ce que le principal
intervenant va dire puisque il y a
personne dans la salle il bouge tout le
temps face à une espèce de truc à côté
vous êtes d'une sagesse remarquable
vous allez voir ce que c'est que le
chaos généralisé
donc la réalité c'est que Macron il a un
discours enrobant et une réalité dedans
Macron c'est celui qui veut la
négociation et qui utilise notamment ce
que les Chinois viennent de faire et
c'est pas à nous qui sommes les éléments
majeurs c'est les troisième partenaires
ceux de la réalité alternative du monde
alternatif que voulait créer Poutine et
donc qui vient de s'effondrer sous ses
pieds les Chinois ont signé la fin de la
partie ils ont le feu les Indiens ont
dit le moment est venu de la paix les
Turcs ont dit vous êtes gentils les gars
mais moi les drones j'ai les fournis au
ukrainiens et ils vous font des NDA donc
le moment est venu d'arrêter en fait
c'est le chant du signe de Poutine il a
quatre semaines pour décider de
exactement comment il veut arrêter cette
guerre et à quel prix il veut l'arrêter
car la mobilisation générale c'est pas
300000 personnes c'est entre 5 et 10
000 capables de se battre c'est-à-dire
rien du tout au vu des pertes il faut
savoir quand six mois il a perdu plus de
monde que dans toute la garde
Afghanistan comme TF oui mais au lieu au
lieu de vouloir se faire respecter
absolument par Poutine est-ce que Macron
n'aurait pas plutôt intérêt à faire des
clins d'oeils à la Chine au final
vous dit qu'il ne les fait pas mais
peut-être un peu plus officiellement un
vrai clin d'oeil ça se voit pas beaucoup
enfin sauf dans les Hauts sauf dans les
offres de l'émission de mars
l'essentiel aux Nations Unies c'est pas
le discours que vous voyez c'est ce que
vous voyez pas dans les couloirs non
mais c'est vrai que après après on
voudrait revenir dessus parce que
regardez le sondage juste avant vous
allez vous allez comprendre oui 32%
67%, non voilà s'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup français voilà on parle un
petit peu sérieusement qui disent c'est
vrai que c'est pas c'est pas notre
guerre et c'est ce que disait Daniel
vraiment Daniel tu voulais réagir j'ai
l'impression qu'en fait
ce que finalement entre la Russie et les
États-Unis et qu'on veut exister vous
l'avez dit vous-même et moi j'ai pas
envie qu'on prenne un risque de se
prendre une bombe sur la tête parce que
Emmanuel Macron veut exister même au nom
de la France
c'est pas notre guerre ils ont fini par
y rentrer avec
moi je sais que voilà ça me fait peur
les gens qui montrent un peu leurs bras
ma grand-mère disait il veut péter plus
haut que son derrière on a pas beaucoup
de moyens
à tout prix préserver la paix on rend la
guerre inévitable et c'est ce que j'ai
passé plus on repousse plus on va faire
un coup alors
Jean-Michel tu es seul avoir mis oui
regardez oui parce que en fait je croise
je crois qu'elle a que que Poutine ne
comprend que le langage de la violence
et le rapport de force les les
négociations de ça ils sont pas
complètement où il a des objectifs tant
que les aura pas atteints ils s'arrêtera
pas donc on veut l'arrêter où on est
très cynique on décide de lâcher prise
et on lui laisse on le lui laisse
sucrerne c'est une solution on l'a déjà
fait dans d'autres pays ou alors on
décide on décide de l'affronter à ce
moment-là faut y mettre les moyens il
faut que tout le monde se se coalise
pour pour arrêter le truc mais bon
intermédiaires en fait il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de Français qui vraiment sur
les réseaux sociaux qui disent pourquoi
on est aussi impliqué dans cette guerre
alors qu'il y a plein de conflits dans
lesquels nous ne sommes pas allés voilà
ici voilà c'est c'est ce que ce que je
demande énormément de français c'est
pour savoir la Seconde Guerre mondiale
il nous l'a dit Monsieur Bauer il y a
1940 en fait c'est notre jurisprudence à
nous on laisse un peu quand même bah oui
non enfin moi j'ai je vous ai écouté
c'est une masterclass j'ai vraiment j'ai
adoré tout ce que vous avez expliqué
pour autant
savoir si même si on a une toute petite
place diplomatiquement et vous l'avez
très bien expliqué est-ce que ça sert de
parler à Poutine parce que Macron on
s'en d'orgueilli de parler souvent à
Poutine est-ce que ça a été utile vous
pensez moi ma vie c'est de parler à des
criminels absolument horribles tout le
temps pour comprendre pourquoi ils l'ont
fait comment ils l'ont fait et comment
éviter qu'il leur fasse donc je ne
discute absolument pas de qui est en
face de moi je suis pas prof de morale
moi mon métier c'est prof de
criminologie et éventuellement voilà
c'est le le nouveau livre de chevet de
Cyril qui va pouvoir
je voudrais simplement dire il y a une
phrase que nationale pour les du
prononcer puisque c'est le spécialiste
des citations c'est quoi simple
Parabellum si tu veux la paix il faut
préparer la guerre et préparer la guerre
c'est pas inciter à faire la guerre
c'est juste dire que le prix de la
guerre est trop important pour comment
pour la commencer et pour trouver les
instruments de la négociation
paradoxalement c'est plutôt ce que
Macron avait essayé de faire qui n'a pas
bien marché mais ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas recommencer jusqu'au moment où
il y aura assez c'est le feu parce que
le C c'est le feu s'est arrêté d'avoir
des milliers de civils morts et blessés
sont des frappes indistinctes qui ne
touchent pas des forces armées mais des
gens innocents qui sont là juste sous
les bons